You,
your people are turning to social media
almost before they turn anywhere you're
looking, you know, I, when I hear
about something I almost always,
before I even Google it, I almost always
go to Twitter and check Twitter and,
and you know, and see what's going on
and see talks that go at duck duck, go.
Have you heard of that one? No. It's that,
it's like a privacy focused search engine.
It's like pretty much the only
privacy alternative to Google.
It's like this idea that we say, I'll
just Google it. Right. Why do we,
I mean our whole process has been to
like purge proprietary surveillance tools
from our company and I've been trying
to get myself like getting off Facebook,
getting off Twitter,
getting off Instagram.
It's just like there's so abusive to
everybody and it's like there's brilliant
people who work there.
I mean Instagram is such a well designed
app or you can call me beautiful.
But so what do you think is
abusive about it particularly?
There's start with Twitter. They're all
the same. They're all the same. Yeah.
Do you think they're all the same?
Because they're all gigantic businesses.
Yeah.
And they're all the same because none
of them share their source code and they
all spy on everybody and they don't show
you what is happening behind the scenes.
They don't show you what the
code is doing. So like in that,
in that note I wrote to the other day,
it's like I compare it to like
food transparency. You know,
50 years ago nobody thought about that.
And then 20 years ago everyone's like,
I want to know what's in my food white.
But why wouldn't you want to
know what's in your apps? Yeah.
I mean it's super sketchy what
they're doing, but how, so look what,
what superskin we don't know.
But we know that they're
spying on everyone and
tracking you everywhere you go.
They're targeting things at you based
on physical location, browser history,
even when you're not on those websites,
some of their following you around where
you're going on the Internet. Right.
And so some people except that for this
free search engine would free email and
things along those lines.
The PSAP except the fact that a certain
percentage of what they're doing is not
going to be private,
or at least their searches are not going
to be probably like if you circle you
thinking about buying a jeep and you
searched jeeps, you look at, you know,
2019 jeep and then all of a sudden
all your Google ads are about jeeps,
right? They're like, we know, we
know you thinking about cheap bill,
and I don't think that that makes people
want to spend more time on Google and
Facebook. If Fred he does, do
you think it freaks them out?
I think that we're just numb
to it and so we accept it,
but I think it's more that.
Yeah.
And so there's all different layers of
like what we use with your browsers,
your apps, your operating
system, your food,
your government,
your energy.
Like all of this technology has code,
right? That's associated with it. So,
and when you open up your computer,
when you sign into a browser,
when you open up an app,
you are empowering that APP.
That's how the apps of the world
become huge, monstrous corporations.
This because we all use them everyday,
right? So if you switch from, you know,
oh at Macko s to like a new Linux
or like Debbie and urban too,
if you use brave or Firefox, if you, um,
you know, ductile goes actually
proprietary, which is annoying,
but they are very privacy focused.
And then there's Apps, there's mines,
there's all sorts of,
there's other open source,
decentralized social networks out there
that we can potentially federate with.
There's really cool new interesting
protocols like dat and IPFS that are like
more torrent style backend.
So there's actually no servers in a
giant warehouse like Facebook and Google.
It's more,
it's fully peer to peer and we're trying
to balance it because it's not like
decentralization equals good
and centralization equals
bad. But like, you know,
in order to get a suite app,
like Instagram style,
you need servers to like process video.
And so the tech is still sort of
immature in the fully peer to peer, like,
you know, bitcoin style internet.
But we're definitely getting there.
And I just think it's important for people
to use things that are transparent to
them and respecting our freedom.
Yeah.
I think one of the problems with these
giant companies is that once they become
big,
he kind of used them as a default.
And it's very difficult to get people
to communicate with you off of them.
You know? It's a hard to say, hey man,
I'm launching this new social media APP.
I would imagine you could speak to this.
I'm launching this new social media
APP and, uh, I want you to join it.
People like put them already on fucking
Facebook. I'm already on Google.
I'm Ernie on Instagram. I don't want to do
that, man. It's too much, too much extra.
And we make it a million times harder
for ourselves because we're not scooping
into people's contacts and taken
all their information. You are not,
we're mines. No. Okay. So like when
you give your address book to an App,
who does that? Every most apps would be
you gotta be an Asshole, you know? No.
But when you say,
oh,
I want to find my friends who are on
this app and you share your contacts,
we not supposed to do that.
You're not supposed to do that yet.
But most people do.
And you know,
your friends didn't give you permission
to give Facebook their phone number.
Do you do that?
Used to like seven,
eight years ago when
everybody don't do it anymore.
I always say the same thing when it
pops up kit though. Fuck Outta here.
That's always what I say.
Would you like to share your,
your contacts get the fuck outta
here. No, you can't have my contacts.
You asshole. I know what you're doing.
Facebook is a weird one man. It's so,
it's such a sneaky one. You know,
Facebook and you know like all this,
uh, the, the congressional hearings
and the inner workings of it all.
And there the fact that
it profits off of outrage.
So it wants people to argue like the,
the Ai,
the computer learning specifically wants
people to have like contentious debates
about things cause that keeps
their eyes focused on the website.
And if your eyes are focused on Facebook,
you know,
then those Facebook ads are very
valuable. It's really fascinating, man.
I think the outrage is unavoidable
on any network. It's more,
you know, are you gonna? Are you gonna
take down there taking down outrage, Tom?
Yeah, sure. So, and it just seems
so inconsistent and subjective.